[Applause]
on the american side of the busiest land
crossing between the u.s and canada not
a wheel is turning
traffic on the ambassador bridge had
been stopped in both directions now on
the other side from canada to the u.s
just a trickle of trucks is allowed
through
on monday hundreds of angry truckers
disrupted north america's most bustling
international commercial connector and
they say they'll keep it up until
vaccine mandates and other covet-19
restrictions are abolished on both sides
of the border in a heated exchange in
canada's parliament prime minister
justin trudeau insists canada won't be
bullied
you can't end a pandemic with blockades
you can't end a pandemic by decreeing it
you can't even end it by legislation you
need to end it with science you need to
end it with public health measures and
even as canadians are tired and
impatient for it to end we're going to
continue to be there for them to support
them through it and to make sure we do
everything necessary to end this
the protesting truckers say they'll
continue their blockade as long as it
takes
so far police have been reticent to
clear the roads you know it's just
domino effect a whole bunch of stuff
added up and that's what it turned out
to be is guys
hate to say it but best off
each day hundreds of millions of dollars
in commerce crosses the ambassador
bridge including 25 of canada's total
global exports so with billions at stake
each hour and each day the chance of a
confrontation between police and
protesting truckers increases
in the u.s and in canada patience is
wearing thin
it will have to be a result one way or
the other i'm not saying that to suggest
that you know we're going to go in with
battering rams
and a thousand police officers that may
not be the solution
but there has to be a resolution to get
this border crossing open so that we do
not impact the economies of the united
states and canada
as the standoff wears on it remains to
be seen whether the first to lose
patients will be the protesting truckers
or police john hendren al jazeera on the
u.s canadian border